Bounty hunting is a complicated process
Don't you agree?
Hey, everybody it's Charlie we have our first trailer for Star Wars the Mandalorian on Disney Plus coming later this year
So we got to break it down. I will be doing episode videos for this
So be sure to subscribe to get all the videos and when it actually does start
I will do giveaways for Disney Plus subscriptions and it will be rolling out internationally, too
So if you live outside the United States, you will be able to get Disney Plus eventually the series is gonna be 8 episodes
They're gonna air one episode per week, and the first episode will premiere
November 12th
When they launch the Disney Plus streaming service
The footage in the trailer here is just a little bit different from the trailer that they showed off way back at Star Wars Celebration
It's 5 years after Return of the Jedi and the Battle of Endor. There's no central government. The Empire is in ruins
They lost their power base, but the New Republic government hasn't evolved out of the embers of the rebellion yet
So it's complete chaos is what they're explaining
So a lot of the series is inspired by old westerns like Clint Eastwood's man with no name
so picture a lot of these outer rim territory towns being a lot like Tatooine like the planet thereon looks very
Tatooine like because of all the sand, but this isn't meant to be
Tatooine and obviously the series will visit a bunch of different planets his ship is called the razor crest
It actually reminds me a lot of the ship from back during Clone Wars
Even though Jon Favreau implied that Boba Fett will not show up on the series. There will be a lot of Easter eggs for
everything from all the Star Wars movies
One of the ones you may have already spotted is the gun, the rifle, that he's using is actually the exact same rifle that Boba
Fett had during the Star Wars Christmas special when the character debuted in the Star Wars universe
For the very first time so they even have Star Wars Christmas special Easter eggs in this series
The scene at the beginning of the trailer here is the
Mandalorian going to pick up a bounty that he's just learned about that's almost too good to be true
He's being hired by Werner Herzog's character who's the administrator of this sort of Fringe town in the outer territories?
Who's hiring him to find Someone.
That someone is actually a little girl that you see later in the trailer huddling with her mother here
But he offers him a bunch of Beskar, and that's the special metal that Mandalorians use to make their armor and their weapons
It's ultra rare and ultra valuable. So it's almost like he's giving him a mountain of cash
So to speak to go pick up this little girl and bring her back
But as you can tell from the tone of the trailer, he does not seem like a very good person
You also see a lot of Imperial stuff going on with a lot of stormtroopers
You see Giancarlo Esposito from Breaking Bad in a Tie pilot's uniform
Like he used to be captain in the Empire and now he's just a minor warlord, because you have all these
Generals that are left over, the ones that didn't die, either turned into warlords or they were killed at the battle of Jakku
Before the events of Star Wars Episode seven and the rise of the First Order. That's a whole other thing happening way
Later in the timeline - this is happening much closer to Return of the Jedi
We aren't anywhere near the rise of the First Order when this is all happening
The fact that he's walking past these stormtrooper helmets is just meant to let you know that the Empire has fallen
even though
Technically there's still a lot of systems that are loyal to the Empire's way of thinking, as you see him get into fights with
stormtroopers and you see this giant 8080 Walker and other Imperial weaponry and
Technology, the way Jon Favreau and Dave Filoni who also helped him create the series the master of all Star Wars television series
They said that it wasn't like the galaxy suddenly raised their arms up in cheers when the Empire fell there were a lot of people
That really liked the way the Empire did things the orders that they brought even if it was a very oppressive
Order so that just lends itself to this chaotic environment where you have people like Werner Herzog's character, Giancarlo Esposito
And a bunch of other Imperials rising up trying to maintain the Empire's Way of life
Even though technically they aren't around anymore
Carl Weathers plays the leader of the bounty hunters guild that Pedro Pascal's
Mandalorian character belongs to. They don't give him a name. They just call him 'The Mandalorian'.
We don't know if he actually does wind up taking his helmet off during this series
I'm sure he will at some Point,
but for a little while they'll maintain status quo for Boba Fett at least in the original trilogy
You finally found out what Jango Fett and then Boba Fett looked like during the prequels
But I don't know if they're going to be referencing any of that stuff
Most of this is pulling from the original trilogy because it's happening right after the events of those movies
Gina Carano's character is another bounty hunter. She's called Cara dune
She's a former shock trooper who just never adjusted to civilian life after the end of the Empire and the rebellion's war
So now she's part of this bounty hunters guild if you've seen any movie with Gina Carano kicking ass
You can imagine what she's going to be like during the series really cool to see them riding dewbacks
This one either seems like it's been shot by this other bounty hunter or just keeled over from exhaustion
This Twi'lek is just another member of that bounty hunters guild. Really nice iconic shot of him walking across the horizon line
Just like a classic western movie. The IG-88 looking droid is Taika Waititi
He's voicing that character, but they did say that his IG-11 is not IG-88
It's just another bounty hunter droid of the same
Make and model as IG-88. This scene of the Mexican standoff inside Werner
Herzog's office here was in that earlier trailer that they showed off
They didn't post that online, but there's some potato quality footage floating around
It's from the scene when he first walks in to Werner Herzog's office here, and he has a separate character named. Dr Pershing
who walks in from another room startles the Mandalorian, then sets off the three-way Mexican standoff.
Werner Herzog's character makes a joke about how he's outnumbered four-to-one and he says I like those odds
There's a really cool really tough standoff moment. Now the really badass cantina scene
I love this takedown - he actually hooks someone and draws them halfway
Into the doorway the circular door shuts on him cutting him in half
So it's letting you know this is gonna be a pretty hardcore series if he's gonna be taken down people like this
Love the shots of all the bounties that he's collected and put in carbonite
Boba Fett style big callback while Werner Herzog's characters talking about bounty hunting is a very dangerous profession
Isn't it?
early
Predictions for the series just based on the way these narrative tropes play out if you've ever watched any kind of classic Western any kind
Of Clint Eastwood movie is that he's hired to find a bounty that bounty winds up being a little girl
he winds up sympathizing with her in trying to protect her from
The person that hired him to take the bounty werner herzog
winds up being a bigger villain than he lets on at the beginning of the series what tends to happen when you renege on a
bounty that you've been paid a ton of money for is
The person that hired you hires other bounty hunters to go kill you and bring in the bounty
He's a member of Carl Weathers bounty hunters guild
There's probably a bunch of other people that he's known for a long time either maybe done jobs with or maybe been frenemies with who
Will wind up being hired to come after him by the end of the series
I wouldn't say that they're friends or anything like that
But they do look like they've been friendly in the past or they've helped each other out on jobs
so everybody post your reactions in the comments below what they also announced that this panel is that the Clone Wars
Season 7 will be dropping in February next year and they confirmed that the Obi-Wan
Star Wars series will start shooting next year. They finished all the scripts. It'll also probably be about 8 episodes
They brought Ewan McGregor out on stage
I'm guessing it would premiere in
2021 because it takes about a year to turn the episodes around
Most of my predictions about the time period that the show would take place wound up being true
It'll take place around the events of Star Wars Solo making that darth maul post-credit scene that much more important
The timeline is a little wonky with Star Wars rebels and all the other animated series between the big trilogies
But there is a way they can make Darth Maul work on that series
Bring the ship and come to me on Dathomir and you and I will then decide what to do about traitor Beckett.
I'll talk more about Star Wars Obi-Wan when we get some more details about that series
We don't know if Ahsoka is going to star in it too, because that would be a really easy slam-dunk for that series
So if you didn't see me tweeting through the entire panel there was a whole bunch of Marvel stuff
They confirmed miss Marvel. They confirm Moon Knight. They confirmed a she-hulk series
There was a trailer for Marvel phase four with black widow footage with Hawkeye footage a bunch of other stuff also doing videos for that
Tomorrow. They now so many huge things today. My mind was completely blown
So everybody freak out in the comments and while you wait for all that stuff
click here to learn how
Marvel can win spider-man back from Sony into the MCU and click here for my video on the Eternals teaser from comic-con. Thank you
So much for watching everybody. Stay awesome. I'll see you guys tonight